right let's go to turn the page tuesday
so it's those teams and this is an
interesting one that we'll start with
teams that just need to flip that page a
little bit when we get to this tuesday
it's the browns right the cleveland
browns team has been all kinds of beat
up battling some weird injuries finding
ways to win these close games they did
it again this week but barely and they
were going up against the ravens team
that was without lamar jackson for
cleveland what pages they need to turn
there what's the temperature right now
with the cleveland browns
well i mean if you're baker mayfield
sometimes you just need to just keep
things in-house you don't have to tell
the media every single thing every
single thought that you're thinking you
know sometimes it's good just to be
quiet and go you know at the end of the
day i don't know what baker mayfield is
talking about taking the foot off the
gas at the end of the day i was watching
the defense and defense was flying
around miles garage and davey and clown
and them boys was flying around making
plays and just you know doing what
they're doing so
i don't know what baker's talking about
at the end of the day i think he was
really upset that he you know he got
taken out the game and things like that
but baker needs to just continue to
focus on playing good quarterback and
stop worrying about everything else it's
just too many distractions with him
there's going to be more distractions
too because you're going to have eight
players now who are going to enter onto
this coveted list right rod and four of
them are gonna be offensive starters
i'll run you through a few of these
names and you can tell me what you think
right now they're in a position with all
their meetings being held virtually but
jarvis landry wyatt teller austin hooper
all three going to be on that list how
big of a loss is that going to be as
they try to go win this afc north which
is very tight at this point especially
with lamar jackson a little beat up
well jarvis landry he's your he's a
tough guy in the slot he makes those
tough catches and not only that he does
an excellent job in the run game
blocking linebackers blocking strong
safety wyatt teller obviously he's a
lineman you don't want to miss one of
your key linemen and who's the other guy
austin hooper you know they like to run
those two and three tight end packages
all the time and they paid this dude
like 40 something million dollars they
gave him a 40 million dollar deal so
they expect him to be on the football
field and obviously he's not he's got
soft hands good route runner you know
what austin can do good player
he sure is at afc north is going to be
really interesting i'll come back next
segment i'm going to ask you who you
think winds up winning the afc north
gets to our second one on turn the page
tuesday which is the jags the jags and
urban meyer i don't know if you saw that
handshake at the end of the game with
vrabel but there were some dead eyes
from urban buyer he said losing just
sucks the soul out of you jacksonville
urban meyer what's your take
i just think it was such a classless
thing mike vrable is a good dude he's a
really good dude i've known mike for a
long time played with him won two
championships with him and for him to
treat him like that like you go there
and you show a level of class because
you are the leader of that team and
everyone's looking at you and you still
have to treat people the right way
despite going through adversity i was
very disappointed in urban mind we had
this conversation a few weeks ago what
should they do and you asked me i said
well they're probably going to keep them
to work with trevor lawrence to get
better but mike frable did not this
this is inexcusable right here from
urban meyer the arrogance that was so
arrogant you don't even look at a head
coach a grown man in his eye
a guy that you're supposed to respect
man urban every mire is trash i would
get rid of them
i would get rid of them i would get rid
of them because you know what i don't
want a guy like that representing my
organization if i'm a billionaire and i
own a team you think i want that to be
my my head coach you think i want that
to represent the organization that that
i own absolutely not pay him his money
whatever it is and get him out of there
the players don't respect him and he
understands he can't bring that
arrogance you're dealing with guys that
are multi-millionaires you can't come up
in there and just think that that that
you're going to be respected you got to
earn that respect these guys are
multi-millionaires just like you coach
they don't have to be college kids
kissing your ass they don't have to kiss
your butt these guys are pros so you
have to treat them such you can't do the
same things that you did in college you
have to come here and earn your stripes
and urban meyer has not done that and
welcome to the nfl
i can't say that i disagree with one
word you just said and he gets into with
marvin jones jr who we both know he's
one of the nicest guys that you'll be
around in the nfl a true family man a
leader a guy who's done it in multiple
different places had success everywhere
he's been
a leader of that entire receiving room
gets into it with him to where they
basically have to separate calls a bunch
of his assistant coaches losers and
here's the crazy james robinson i would
say the vast majority right james
robinson the vast majority of people
agree with you that they got to move on
from urban meyer i'm not sure shad khan
does and shot khan's ultimately going to
be the guy who's making this decision
and it continues to feel like he is
going to try this for another year i
think there will be changes on that
staff i think he will change drastically
who his assistant coaches are but i
don't think they want to write him some
mega check with all the guaranteed money
for a half years work i just don't see
him doing it i think you're going to see
a second season with urban meyer
coaching trevor lawrence and the
jacksonville jaguars and it's going to
be pretty crazy to see because it's only
going to get louder down there in
jacksonville
so i'm glad i don't know man
yeah
i i am too for more reasons than just
the football team let's get to number
three the cowboys offense
they've been struggling a little bit
defense so much better what's going on
with the cowboys offense though do you
think
it's just the the chemistry with the
wide receivers all these wide receivers
they're not playing all the time they're
not practicing so you just you could
tell the continuity the chemistry the
trust is off and i still think that dak
is having some problems with that leg
whether it's the calf whether it's the
previous injury he doesn't look right
he's compensating and he's not a hundred
percent and he wants the more we talk
about how poorly he's playing and how
bad badly he looks
well he wants to throw the ball even
more and then keller moore as a
offensive coordinator he has to do a
better job in situational you know times
not passing the ball running the
football i i don't know what it is with
these offensive coordinators i think
these guys are so hungry to become head
coaches to put up these spectacular
numbers they just want to pass past pass
run the football
yeah i'm with you on the healthy point
i'm not sure dak has been healthy ever
since that calf injury so he just kind
of looks like he's limping out there to
me looks like he's trying to tough his
way through it but it's not a lot of pop
in his lower body so let's hear from
jerry jones cowboys owner here's what he
had to say about dak press got his
quarterback potential health and all
that applies
do you think dak is in a slump right now
oh i i don't want to say uh that
uh
slump
uh but
that's a that's probably fair
uh but uh it's such a multi-uh
faceted evaluation
uh
but i i would say that our offense is
definitely
uh uh
away from where we were playing uh five
and six games ago
yeah well first of all we got to get
jerry jones a podcast we had to get him
off 105.3 the fan there but let's get
into some dak prescott numbers right so
this is how he's looking first eight
games to the last four games this is
what it looks like right he comes back
and even when he first started playing
rod everyone's going maybe we give him
an extra month to get out this is a
pretty brutal injury that he's working
his way back from but from very first
game against the bucks he was awesome
ever since that calf injury though been
a different story
yeah absolutely it's been a different
story and that's why we talked earlier
about the importance of the defense
stepping up and carrying micah parsons
and those guys randy gregory making
plays and the fact that they now have
both their defensive ends back healthy
that allows micah
parsons even more freedom whether he's
coming off the edge outside of gregory
whether he's coming in the middle or
dropping in coverage it provides them
with you know even more so
i don't know man what's going on with
the dallas cowboys if they're going to
get back to running the football or or
what's going to happen with the
offensive line it's just been crazy but
i know one thing that needs to um they
need to evaluate dak and either let him
rest for a week or two or you know he
needs he needs to play well he needs to
play better
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports